what would you say are the most
frustrating myths that you have seen as
a medical doctor
so far in the news or currently well I
think we see a lot now that the virus is
changing it's getting weaker it's
getting strong mutating we have
different strains in California and New
York it was in New York's fault because
they have a bad strain we had a good
strain here in California here that all
of these things just aren't real we're
not going to catch it probably from
surfaces we're gonna catch it from
droplets right takes about a thousand
droplets for me to spread it to you and
every time I breathe I breathe out about
40 droplets most of them hit the ground
from gravity I have a really big mouth I
feel like I breathe that way my job
you're probably in the 60 or 70 but
that's a different issue but so at a
dinner party with 10 people one person
has it they're sitting at a table for 90
minutes only the person or two on either
side will get it the others won't
because social distancing works right
wearing a mask works above it everybody
in the room here is wearing a mask
we're just social distance and say but
that works